if you were to get notes and maybe they
wouldn't put it in these terms but to
dumb down a script oh yeah had that
happen oh you have okay in those exact
words okay so what is dumbing it down
and what would that be and what is like
braying raising the vibration if you
want to use it yeah term no I mean um I
wrote a script and returned to Cambodia
like actually it was a TV movie and it
was a sequel and Jed Nelson was in the
first one and so they got the him back
and the director back based on my script
and literally the one of the creative
executives like called the producer
probably about a month before they
started shooting and was like you know
we think the scripts just too smart for
our audience so we're gonna bring
somebody into to dumb it down and so all
that meant was that they just went for
the very generic with the characters
it's just the base generic stuff so it's
like it was based on a the first movie
was based on the killer who needed
inspiration so he started murdering
people and he lived in a cabin by the
lake and would murder people women and
drown them in the lake and then he would
write about it so I wrote a script that
was about then making a movie about the
the first movie so it was kind of very
screamish and so like in my script this
is his one simple instant but they might
script like he was dating the lead
actress and so all these other actresses
was like throwing themselves at the
director and he was like in love with
what the leading actor so he and they're
like what you know he should be sleeping
with all the actresses I'm like but
that's like the obvious that's just the
most obvious stereotype like I'm trying
to do something different so they made
you know so that's dumbing it down it's
like going for just the base like
simplest thing we can do with no nuance
and I think if you if you when I've
gotten notes that the script needs to be
elevated it's just because I haven't
done enough work on the characters you
know there's not there's not enough
depth their interactions there are
actions maybe you're very on the surface
in some scenes or the story's very maybe
those points in the story they're very
on the nose so I think you're I think
nuance is usually when they want when
I'm asked to elevate something see a bit
add more layers or to add more nuance to
something but yeah dumbing it down I
mean that was a prime example where it's
just like they they're like he should
just be sleeping with everybody because
he's a director and the producer should
be doing coke and you know so it's just
and so it was and so they brought one of
their people on it
like they didn't even tell me and the
producer would not even ask her to send
me this screener that the script and
she's like I can't I'm like is it that
bad she's like I can't
I remember watching with some friends I
was like I was in there like a little
tear like that in the end when you lit
her like on the side I like a little
tear went down my eye was like wow
but it's it's pretty funny watching it I
mean it's it's a campy movie so in the
director I think once he saw it I think
he cuz he's signed on based off my
original script and I think when he saw
this she newsroom he's like screw it I'm
just gonna make this like a comedy and
so he just like went really over-the-top
and guns I was like the sound effects
and everything so it's almost him was
shot like a comedy version of a horror
movie so it's it's pretty interesting to
watch now I don't I should have kept a
copy it's like selling on eBay for like
a hundred and some bucks now bro I know
I was like wow I should have kept
economy and if we thought about it so do
you get more notes to dumb something
down or to flesh something out um I get
more notes at the writing stage to flesh
this out but and I think one thing is I
want to production that's when things
start getting you know especially in
horror movies there were like we need to
get to the kills quicker like that's the
kind of the common note that I get for
Horus we need to get to the kills
quicker so any jokes or character stuff
that they can cut out they'll try to cut
out just to get to the kills quicker so
I wouldn't even say it's dumbing it down
unfortunate I would just say it's you
know they just want to get right to the
blood and the murder so is there a time
frame when the movie starts you know
like within 30 minutes there should be
conflict or whatever yeah same thing is
there yeah with films it's usually
there's usually having a death in the
opening of a horror film and then you
know ten ten minutes and or fifty
minutes and you have another one and you
you kind of keep up they want you to
keep up a steady tick with them so it's
um interesting when movies don't do that
and I've certainly written stuff where
there there hasn't been a death in the
opening but then people you know you
start watching it and it's like people
want to get to that death quicker so if
you test market it or you or do a test
screen not test my but if you test
screen the film people might be uh took
a while to get to that first kill or it
started off boring and they're like okay
they want you know so sometimes the
answer is actually just shoot of death
seem to stick in the beginning of it
you get it out of the way yeah cuz I'll
buy you some I've learned to do that
Natalie cuz I've tried in other films
not to do that and I've just learned
that if you if you open with a really
big death that will give you a lot of
like real estate to build your story
it's not cuz people will still be thing
about that death for a good five or ten
minutes and so you've got some time like
build characters and not have to jump
right into another one right away so
instead of the hero's journey the serial
killers turn right there's different
things that they need to follow as well
yeah and then too in terms of the the
evil character are is there times when
you know it you're making him to
humanized or to to likable can you tone
them down and make them so you don't
know what the motive for yeah I mean
I've written a couple of like thriller
kind of horror movies and I think you
want for me it's like you want to either
have a villain that that just terrifies
everybody completely or is a fun bill
and because they kind of relish the bad
stuff they're doing so it depends on
what kind of killer they are I mean you
don't want to romanticize your killers
like if you know and I try to stay away
from even though I watch him and I love
them but I try to save from more of like
the torture II like you know let's like
let's tie a woman up and like torture
for 10 minutes and that's how a guy open
towards Jim for 10 minutes like I try to
stay away from that kind of stuff cuz it
just doesn't hold my interest for very
long when I was young I did because it
was bloody and that's all I cared about
but but you know if it's a killer like
that you don't want to humanize them I
don't think because it doesn't because
in your in this weird place where it's
like okay I'm just watching this person
like torture people for 90 minutes and
now you're trying to make me have
sympathy for them and you know it's
again there's enough of that in real
life like there's enough sure you know
there's just enough really bad people
out there in real life though I think
when you go to watch them horror movie
you want to be like scared entertained
but it's still you want to escape I
think you you don't want to go there to
be reminded of like real life stuff so
yeah real life sociopath is gonna be
like the neighbors like oh he was such a
nice guy even though he's quiet and he
was chopping up people so it's like you
don't want to necessarily have that be
your your killer in a horror film well
going back to carry though you could see
why she got to that stage yeah and you
just like you had said and I felt the
exact same
I wish he'd gone to that stage earlier
yeah but so I think with Carrie you were
able to feel maybe more empathy yeah she
was never I mean because it kept they
kept had John Travolta and oh my gosh
I'm blanking on the character's name but
the mean you know the girl yeah a mean
girl and you know so you had the
villains who were actually so she was
still she was always the hero that just
got pushed to the breaking point and so
you can you can have it I think somebody
like that you can have somebody who we
get to see turned dark because of the
circumstances they're put into but if
it's a kind of a traditional hormone who
you've got like the good you know the
good person versus the the evil killer
like I think there's you want to you
want the audience that maybe understand
where the person is coming from but if
you get too far into where they
sympathize with them like I think that's
one of the reason the one of the
disagree to me my friends have about
that movie don't breathe you know I
thought it was beautifully shot and well
done but I thought the program I won't
spoil anything for anybody I thought
that the protagonist the kids were very
unlikable
and then I thought the antagonist they
went too far to make you sympathize with
why he was doing what he was doing like
we need you know but the whole set of
this is in the previews but when the
whole set up is three kids are gonna go
bot go rob a blind veteran you know that
kind of you're kind of set up some
character that you're like yeah we don't
really like and then you find out this
isn't a spoiler either but the money
he's got the money because his daughter
got killed by a drunk driver so it's
like okay you're really bad people no
like you're robbing from a blind veteran
who has money because his daughter got
killed by a drunk driver so it's hard to
you know so they throw him beat they
throw in moments in the movie where they
you know flashbacks or scenes where they
try to make you they try to force you to
feel like some sympathy for the
characters but it for me it just didn't
you know I was just like you look you
lost me at the beginning and then they
didn't they made the villain so so
sympathetic that you actually yep I
wanted him to like end up just killing
them at the end of it which is not I
don't think what you want a movie
you